good morning okay so I'm here to talk to
you about s trace the idea of s trace
it's it's a kind of tool that you can
use to monitor the conversations going
on between a user space application and
the kernel unless you watch all the
system calls that a process is making
when you're communicated with with with
the Linux kernel underneath its
implement using a system call called P
trace and the point is it's a kind of
debugging tool that you can use to
monitor the complete conversation that
happens between the application and the
users base all the system calls that are
being made and obviously you can answer
questions like what sort of system calls
is the application making what files is
the application touching what are the
arguments being passed to each system
call did the system call succeed or not
and if it failed why did it fail I just
mentioned passing there's a loosely
related command called L trace and L
trace is about tracing calls through
shared libraries and so it's it's an
analogous tool you can use to watch
what's going on with the shared
libraries through your applications
using I'm not going to talk about it at
all I just mentioned it because it's a
range tool it actually has quite a
similar interface and you might also
find that useful to learn about okay the
beauty of s trace is it gives you
everything in symbolic form okay you get
system call system calls being displayed
to you by name when there are signals
involved you see the names of the
signals and signal numbers when strings
are being used as arguments you see the
strings being printed out by default up
to a certain limit 32 bytes but you
can't ask you get more of each string
being displayed things like bit masks
for certain system calls those bit masks
are displayed symbolically in other
words s trace has built-in logic where
it understands each different system
call and what the flags arguments of
those system calls mean and it it has
the bits decoded into symbolic form for
every different system call when it
displays structures to you
it displays the structures in a nice
sort of C format braces and each field
is shown with its name by default and
when when system calls fail and you get
an error in the global urn over it
variable you see the name of that error
in symbolic form and you see the textual
description of that error and by default
large arguments and structures are
breviary by default but you can't ask
for the full format of those structures
the full display of those structures so
here's an example of the kind of output
you might see when using that expanded
output from air stress where we've got a
call to a system call here called F stat
if state takes two arguments one of the
arguments is a file descriptor which is
just an integer but the other argument
is a structure that's returned by the
system call and what we see here is an
opening brace for the structure a
closing brace for the structure and then
each one of the fields is displayed to
us in a labeled with its value and all
of the fields that are should be
displayed symbolically are displayed
symbolically so to take one example
here's a time stamp field and the time
stamp field gets shown to us as a date
and a time taking another example here
this st mode field the st mode field
gives us two pieces of information about
the file its permissions mode and also
the file type now the permissions mode
here is displayed in octal because most
people understand octal permissions
masks on on unix linux systems but the
file type is shown to us
using the standard constant used in the
header files for this particular file
type so it's not displayed to us
numerically instead we see s I F reg
this is a regular file another example
the first field here s T dev this is
telling us what device this file lives
on okay yes that is giving us
information to back about a file this is
the device that this file lives on now
devices on Unix Linux systems are
identified by a combination of a major
and a minor ID the major IDE ID tells us
what kind of device it is the minor IDs
is which particular instance of the
device it is and there's a standard
macro in the header files called make
dev that takes those two numbers
combines them to make a bigger number
and that macro is used to display to us
the the the device ID okay another
example here we've got open open takes a
path name and a Flags argument again the
flags argument is displayed symbolically
open returns to us a file descriptor
assuming it succeeds and we see the file
descriptor number being displayed there
its file descriptor number 3 so let's
take a very simple C program all it does
is write out a string and terminate and
then we'll run s trace on that program
by default s trace sends its output to
standard error but we can ask it to send
the output to a tour to a file instead
so here I'm saying send the output to a
log file I run the program the program
produces some output and oh there's a
little step I need to mention a long way
well look at that log file in just a
moment on some Linux systems there's a
security module that's installed which
by default disables the use of the P
trace system call except in limited
cases so if you find that you try and S
trace something on your system and it
doesn't work what you might need to do
is check do you have this file on your
system
and doesn't have the value zero inside
and if it doesn't they need to put zero
in that file and then you can use s
trace otherwise there's an unprivileged
user you can't use s trace okay so when
we look inside that file we see a whole
bunch of output so I've edited the
output here quite a bit it was actually
about 25 lines or so in this particular
case a lot of those lines were to do as
loading of shared libraries that
happened at the start of the execution
of the program so we will see lines like
this where we're a fire certain files
being opened in this case it's the cache
file being used by the dynamic dynamic
linker and in map calls are being the in
met pool here is probably to do I was
gonna say it's to do with mapping some
shared library but maybe the cache
library the cache file is being mapped
in as well
but what we see down towards the end is
information about the system calls that
were actually in our C code there's a
whole lot of calls that happen at the
start to do with C runtime start up
dynamic linking and so on but then
towards the end we see the system calls
that we actually explicitly made in our
program and here's the right call it had
we wrote on the file descriptor one
standard output a string a certain
length the return value of right was 12
right tells us how many bytes is written
then we see something that's a little
bit surprising because going back here
this was a call to the exit library
function now if you if you know how UNIX
systems work you know that the exit
library function called an an underlying
system call called underscore exit and
so that's what you might expect to see
in the s trace log instead we're seeing
a call to something else exit group now
jump for they're a little bit
if you go and look in the manual pages
closely enough you'll find a lot of
annotations these days that looked like
this see library colonel differences and
you go and read through and you see
Angie Lipsy since version 2.3 the
underscore exits API is actually a
wrapper function in the C library that
instead calls exit group so sometimes
you have to do a bit of detective work
to understand what you're seeing in the
S trace outputs okay so I sort of
covered a lot of this already but the
point is gained in the symbolic output
we're seeing the names of system calls
we're seeing the values passed in as
arguments we're seeing for each system
call a return value some system calls
don't return a value so exit group for
instance doesn't return so we see a
question mark there and in the case of
system calls that fail like this access
system called here we see the return
value as minus one Ino int is the
symbolic value or the symbolic name of
the value that appears in the ER no
variable telling us what kind of error
this was and in this case it's telling
us no entry in the files and this this
path name doesn't exist and also on the
next line we see the standard textual
description of that error no such file
or directory
okay now by default we'll use s trace if
we try and trace us a program what we'll
see is the system calls that are made by
the process that executes that program
if that process or that program creates
child processes by default we don't see
the trace output for those child
processes but we can ask to do so we can
say it's trace - F and then we see not
only the program that we wanted that we
started getting traced but also the
child processes that it creates now
every line of output in the S Trace out
is prefixed by a PID this even works
with programs that use threads by the
way POSIX threads for example in this
case each line gets prefixed by the
kernel thread IDE that is used
underneath to implement the POSIX thread
and so again a little example here I've
got a program that creates a child
process using fork fork returns 0 if
when the child returns and the child
prints out a message and maybe if it was
a command-line argument the child will
try an exec command unless you're gonna
try and do that in the demonstration
that we'll see in just a moment
the parent meanwhile waits for the child
to terminate and I run the program here
no argument so it doesn't try and exec
any other program so there's going to be
a fork to create a child process the
Choppers is going to print a message and
then terminate meanwhile the parent is
going to wait for the child to terminate
and then the parent terminates as well
helpfully my program the two processes
print out their pids so we can match
that up in the s trace log so when we do
that now what we see is every line
begins with a a PID telling us which
process is producing the trace output
and so we can see which of the parent
and the child the parent was 1 9 3 9 the
child was 1 9 4 0 which parent which
process is producing the trace output
what we're seeing very first they're the
exact ve call that was used to actually
launch the program now further down
there's a call here to clone and again
this is where you need to do a bit of
detective work but we had a program that
called fork to create a child process
but there's actually no call to fork
here and that's because these days I
don't have forgot it on a slide I
haven't but these days clones
sorry Fork is actually a wrapper Fung
action in the sea library that instead
calls the clone system called clone
provides a sort of superset of the
functionality of fork and so what we
thought was a fork system for actually
underneath is really a clone system call
so that was a clone system call being
made by the parents and then you can see
the parent is calling wait to wait for
the child again we see here there's a
call to wait for we call something named
wait but actually this is a wrapper
function again that underneath calls a
system call called wait for again you'll
find all these details and these little
pieces and the main pages about the
differences between see library and
kernel interfaces so Anderson Lee
happens just here we call wait for we've
asked the minus one here says wait for
any child and the wait for call blocked
it hasn't finished yet
yes trace works this out and that the
splice to us that this call is not yet
finished now here's the child the child
writes a string okay a write system for
the printf underneath was using a write
system call and then the child
terminates by calling the exit library
function and by now we know that
underneath the system call that is being
used is exit group now at that point the
child process terminates
yes trace notices that and so we see
that s trace tells us that process
terminated with exit status zero and at
this point the parent wakes up again
because now it gets informed that the
child processes are now terminated and
the white for call now unblocks and we
see the rest of the arguments that are
being returned by the wait for call and
wait for as well it's return value is
the PID of the child whose status is
being reported what also happens for the
parent in the scenario is
it gets a signal the talent that the
child process terminated and his trace
also can tell us about signals that are
flying around inside our application and
the signal signal that's involved here
is sig child okay the death of a child
process and signals on on Linux systems
and on a lot of other UNIX
implementations as well can be
accompanied with a bunch of other data
that tells us about the origin of the
signal and so we see things like the
information here si code CL the accident
this is telling us that the cause of the
generation of the signal was child
termination and we even see the PID of
the child that terminated the user ID of
that process some other information as
well then the parent terminates and s
trace sees that okay so if you use s
trace to look at any interesting program
what you find is any interesting program
makes thousands of system calls tens of
thousands of system calls so you get
this enormous quantity of output and so
one of these you didn't want to do is
say I want less output you want to
filter the output that you're getting
and there's a few different kinds of
filtering that you can do first of all
there's an S trace - iakh ssin which
allows you
what's your my other things can be used
to select the system calls that you want
to trace so maybe you want to only want
to trace certain system calls to your
applications making then you can say s
trace - e trace equals and then names of
system calls one by one separated by
commas so here we're saying run the
program LS and just trace the open and
close system calls opening and closing
files sometimes or conversely you have
applications that make a lot of system
calls but they make a lot of this
system calls and you actually don't want
to know about those system calls a
classic example is there are some
applications out there that do things
like call and get time of day thousands
of times a second get time of day just
returns the current time kind of strange
thing to do but some applications want
to do it and maybe you don't want to see
all those calls to get time of day in
your S trace output because they're
cluttering up the output and they're not
terribly interesting information for you
so then what you can say is s trace - e
trace equals shriek has a not system
call commerce system call comma system
call one thing you've got to watch out
for here that shriek carries that
exclamation mark is often in two of me
she'll interpret that character with a
special meaning
so quite probably you want to put this
piece in single quotes I don't know
more recently someone had the bright
idea that an S trace you could say
Estrella XI equals trace slash regular
expression so you actually write a
regular expression to select your system
rules it seems kind of excessive to me
there's only a few hundred system calls
and I don't know if I really want to
write regular expressions to select
system calls it seems more than I need
anyway it's a feature that was recently
added one other feature that is
sometimes useful instead of specifying
individual system calls you can say
estrellas - EE tres and then a system
call category and there are a number of
predefined categories that you can
choose yes trace - e trace equals % file
show me all the system calls that take a
file name as an argument or show me all
the system calls that use file
descriptors or the system calls that do
sort of process management tasks things
like process creation with fork or clone
process to terminate
exit group execute a new program wait
for child processes or network related
system calls all the stuff to do with
the socket API socket bind listen and so
on
and signal rated system pulls memory
related system calls there's a few other
categories as well sometimes this is a
convenient shorthand of course rather
than listing a bunch of system calls
individually yourself one of the other
things you can do is you can say maybe
there's a lot of signals flying about as
your application executes and you don't
want to see all of the signals in the
trace output again you can use this
Dashie filter option to select which
signals are being displayed and you say
s trace - e signal equals and then a set
of signals and the set of signals is
just listed by name optionally the names
of the signals can include the sig
prefix but they don't have to and so
here we're saying I want to trace the
sigil and Sigyn signals that happen
during the execution of this application
and again there's a are not
functionality because maybe there's a
certain thing what happens a lot and you
don't want to see the output to do with
that signal so you can say yes trace -
II signal equals not search one other
thing that you can do in terms of
filtering is filtering by path name you
want to find out if your application is
touching a certain path name and win and
with what system calls so you can say s
trace - P path name and you'll see all
the system calls the relate to that path
name and there's some some cleverness
that goes on here so first of all here
I'm saying s trace - P Lib 64 Lib C dot
ISO dot six ideas about which one that
is what file it is
a seed library okay and I'm just saying
four LS send the actual output of LS to
slash dev slash Knowles who don't
actually see us one of the things this
trace works out along the way is that
actually this thing's a symbolic link
that points to another file and so it
tells us what the actual file is that
the symbolic link resolves to and then
we go on the the the logged output and
we see here a call to open that open
that path name certain flags and we got
back a certain file descriptor now s
trace gets a bit clever here it says ah
that file was opened on that file
descriptor everything that happens with
that file description now I'd better
tell the user about it because the user
is interested in what happens to that
file
and so now there's a whole bunch of
system calls later on that all use file
descriptor number three okay we're
reading from that file that we opened
we're doing an if stat on that file that
we opened we're doing an M map from that
file that we opened and so on and so on
and eventually the file gets closed file
destroy the file descriptor gets closed
and at that point s trace of course
works out that hey this file descriptor
is no longer interesting and even if
it's reused later on with another open
on a different file of course it doesn't
show us the system calls that use that
file descriptor there's a few other sort
of related options that you can use in
terms of path names there's an option -
why and when use the - why option then
when file descriptors are displayed it
also displays extra information about
the file descriptor for example the path
name of the associated file so this just
makes it a bit easier for you to read
the s trace output if you read the S
trace output if you didn't use - Y and
you read the s trace output carefully
enough you could always work out what
files drippler 3 refers to but this is a
I kind of aid to make understanding this
trace output even
easier so here we're seeing file
descriptor 3 refers to the path slash
home slash Greece and and so on Oh hmm
I've made a little it mess up editing
that slide that last part name there
should say home MDK breach I tried to
shorten my slides but I failed to me out
of that piece ok
there's also a - YY option okay so it's
tres - why shows you information not
just her files but things like sockets
and pipes as well as some useful
information being displayed there and
for for sockets in particular there's
also an option you can use called - YY
which is give me even more information
about sockets and you get various
protocol rated information being
displayed so here we're seeing file
descriptor 3 it's a TCP socket there's
an IP address associated with that
socket there's a port number and there's
a peer associated with a soft because
this is a stream socket connection so we
see the address the IP address and the
port number of the peer socket as well
one of the features that has been added
more recently to s trace is system call
tampering they used to me you can just
use s trace to trace the execution of
the process you can now use this trace
to interfere with the execution of a
program you can cause certain system
calls to change their behavior in
various ways and this feature in general
is called system called tampering
there's a bunch of different things you
can do you can add a delay before or
after a system fall you can say when a
certain system call is made generate a
signal you can bypass the execution of a
system call so that when that system
call is is is attempted the system call
doesn't actually get executed and
there's various possibilities that you
can do
there you can either bypass the system
call and make it look like it's
succeeded so it returns a set it looks
like it returns a success status or you
can make that make things look like the
system Paul failed with a certain error
number
there's even when it comes to doing the
sort of tampering there's even a sort of
limited facility to say which instance
of this system call should be tampered
with
I'll check my time okay
now the way that you use this tampering
option you say s trace - e inject and
then you list a set of system calls and
then some option one of that says which
one of these things do you want to do to
that system call and there's various
possibilities that these are syntaxes
just correspond to those options you can
say I want to make that system pool fail
with a certain error number you know no
or I want to make it I want to bypass
the system call and make it look like it
returned a certain return value so that
it looks like the system calls succeeded
somehow returning a certain value these
two options just by the by are mutually
exclusive you can't make a system call
succeed and fail ok tell the system
quartet make a deliver a signal when
that system calls attempted or when the
system calls attempted have a delay
before the system calls actually
executes and or a delay after the system
call is executed or both so when a
certain system call happens you can have
things slow right down so that perhaps
while the delay is happening you might
you couldn't be an arbitrarily long
delay then you might do some inspection
of the rest of the environment that the
process is running in because you want
to see how do things look just at the
moment that the process makes that
system call and then as I said there's a
sort of limited facility to choose
which system call you want to interfere
with and you can say : win and then some
sort of expression for instance when
equals in says tamper with the int in
invocation of a certain system call or
tamper with all in invitations starting
at the end call and everyone there
afterwards or every starting a tenth and
then every s yes
step every yes instance of a
notification to that system call okay
it's a very limited form of choosing I'm
sure many people would like what you
like but that doesn't exist yet in this
race it's a start and this feature was
only added you know sort of less than
two years ago for a long time the
development of s tres was fairly fairly
sedate but in the last two or three
years there's been a whole lot of
development work going on a whole lot of
new features being added so who knows
maybe you'll get what you want in the
not-too-distant future
okay so here's an example in where I'm
saying s tres - why why to get him for
extra information about file descriptors
trace the close close calls okay this is
a shorthand here by the way I've said -
e close I could have said - e trace
equals clothes but you can't actually do
it shorter in some cases and then - e
inject for the close calls make them
fail for the with the Erno value 22 but
only make the third close call fail and
so we see here that the program is
making a series of close calls the first
two close calls succeeded again the
program was running
over here is LS we see the first two
close calls do something but then the
third close call looks like it fails
with an error
Ian Val and we see the corresponding
error text for Ian Bell and we also get
an indication from s trace actually this
was an injected error now after this
because Elias tried to use a certain
file and the open failed after alias got
kind of sad and things started to go
things started to go bad okay so Elias
eventually decided hmm I can't go any
further
yes yep oh sorry yes you it's a it's a
good guy sorry y'all do have it here yes
I don't have it here but 22 is the
numeric value of the Ian Valero
unfortunately if to specify the numbers
numerically at least as far as I know so
the roots by the way a little program
around nowadays it's it's a quite useful
little program that is not so well known
and I just show it to you
it's a program called Erno now Mike
might not be just installed by default
on your system but there's a package
called more you tools that is available
for most distributions and it gives you
this little tool and it's really useful
because I can say
ernõ 22 en Val or I can say oh no Ian
Val go the reverse direction this is
quite useful as well when you using the
manual pages because in the manual pages
the errors are listed symbolically but
the error that the errors are actually
numbers and sometimes you actually just
see numbers being output from programs
and you want to say well why I know I've
got a certain error number and I can see
their error names than the manual pages
what does that number mean you could go
and look in the header files that's kind
of painful though this program give you
easy way of doing it okay minus one so
when a system call fails what's
happening is it has a return status
which is typically zero on success or
minus one on fan yeah some system calls
return of some sort of positive value on
fan on success as well but the point is
minus one is return on value and then
there's an additional channel for giving
you further information about the error
which is the Erno global variable and
the Ian velvet a value is what's landing
in the ER no global throw a no-no is a
special variable dedicated to the
purpose of error reporting and s trace
knows this so it's telling you what when
it s Tracie's o minus 1 return o that
means there's going to be something
useful in ernõ and it shows you the
value of Erno okay I just very briefly
mentioned then there are a number of
other options that are potentially
useful from time to time
it's trace - see this says give me a
summary of the system calls that my
program made and what you see here is
the number of system calls that were
made to alarm this is a system call
called alarm and you can see for each
system call if there were system call
instances that failed you can see the
number of system corns invitations that
failed what you also get is some timing
estimates where you you see there's an
estimate here in seconds of how long it
took to make that system fool I I would
totally take this with a grain of salt
because the way s trace works it uses
the pea tray system call and the wipey
trace works when it's monitoring another
process is it stops that process every
time I make it a system called just
before it makes the system call and just
after the system call returns for every
cool so just by the way this trace can
slow a program down quite significantly
because of all of these stops and starts
I can refer got a slide here about it
but one of things you want to be you can
use s trace to trace a live process in
production you can say s trace - P maybe
I've ice I have it here on the next
slide
s trace - P - trace are a running
process with a specified p ID and then
you start seeing live tracing of that
process you can use even use that -
lowercase P option multiple times to
trace several processes at once when you
don't want to try to trace any more you
type ctrl C that stops the tracing
generally you can only trace the
processes you write your own and this
you're a privileged user when you do
this you can really heavily impact the
performance of your application because
every system call results in to stop
starts so if two orders of magnitude
slowed down and system calls is probably
what you can expect think twice before
you do it in a production environment if
you use s trace - P - F then you can
trace all the threads in a
multi-threaded process okay there's a
few other options as well which I'll
just mention very briefly - V says be
verbose don't abbreviate structures and
arguments that are shown to us because
by default its traces if you've got a
very large structure it only displays to
you part of the structure but perhaps
you want to see all the structure you
can use - V by default strings when
they're displayed are limited to 32
bytes of the first 32 bytes of the
string again you can change this as an
option s trace - yes and then string
size just by the way path names s trace
knows that path names are special
regardless of this option would always
displays a complete
the complete path name string when it's
displaying to you information from a
system call there's various options to
show you the start time and duration of
system calls again I would treat this
with a bit of skepticism because of the
way s trace works but they can give you
a flavor of where your program is
spending time in its system calls so - t
+ - TT are options that you can use to
add the wall clock time so you see what
time the system call was made - TT
includes the microseconds as well -
capital T how much time was spent in
each system call one other option that
is occasionally useful S trace - I show
the value of the instruction pointer at
the point where the system call was made
so you can see which part of the code
was making that particular system call
and I'm done
ok just in time there's even time for
one or two questions
yes yes can you also trace a single
thread yes I think you can do that just
by specifying just the thread ID I've
actually never tried that I've always
wanted to trace either the just the the
the main thread or all the threads but
I'm I'd be reasonably sure that you can
just say yes trace - lowercase P and
then the thread ID itself we could
answer that question very very quickly
afterwards okay other questions yes I
think that's the intention the the you
could do this but I think in the what
well I think it's interesting they've
added this it's it's it's not clear to
me that what the real use case is
because there are other ways to do this
better okay in particular you can do
things like LD preload techniques with
shared libraries where you intercept
calls the system calls and have the
preload wrapper make it look like the
system calls succeeded or fail or even
just does something else completely or
you can use sick comp and set comp is a
technique for preventing an application
making certain system calls and one of
the options you've got to say make that
system call look like it failed I'm
going to talk about sitcom actually
tomorrow so yeah it's there as a feature
but it's not the tool I would reach for
first I would be looking at the other
tools first just cuz they offer more
flexibility but maybe the intention is
with s Trace to add no bill on this
functionality so maybe you can do more
powerful things in the future Patricia
sure but I would think about game set
comp probably for doing my blackbox
testing in that case having a a set comp
wrapper that sort of been loads the
program that I want a black box test
just because I like sitcom it's fun but
it is all it is it is also much more
powerful in terms of what you can do it
is I guess the the the one the one thing
I would say in the favor of the inject
take me Forrest race is it is really
simple it's easy to do okay doing set
comp is take some effort doing LD
preload takes some effort
so if perhaps if you want to just do a
quick test what happens if I make that
system pool fail now what does my
application doom so it could be a quick
first shot at seeing you know I do that
black box testing the system call fails
what did my application did it
gracefully handle the error but if I
want to do more sophisticated testing in
terms of black box testing failure mode
testing I would be thinking about the
other tools
okay ah I'm moved
allow you to instrument so can you
instrument a system call value to make
it return a value that wasn't that
should that should never happen sure
it's just a number you know there's
there's no limitation on the oh no value
that you could well practically speaking
there's no limitation there's there is
actually a limitation to do with the way
system court well actually not bet
that's not really limitation in this
case system core error numbers on the
Linux kernel or the g-dub C expects them
what the C loggers expect them to be in
the range 1 to 4 thousand 95 and they
have certain rules around interpreting
the return values of system pools that
are based on that assumption
now the actual error numbers 1 up to a
few hundred so we're no lis nowhere near
that limit of 4095
but I suppose when you're doing
injection with s trace yeah you could
put any over your nono could be above
4,000 95 because this is this is a level
sort of you can create this yes yeah
that just numbers yes
how does estrous handle context
switching well underneath I don't know
the details really but I mean underneath
what's the what's going on here is a
certain system call called P trace and P
trace is just being used to monitor the
process and the way that P traits works
is interfacing to the kernel and the
kernel informs the user of s trace sorry
P trace every time something happens
with that process that a system call
relators so yes it's all been the
colonel knows that a certain process is
being traced it knows the identity of
the tracing process and so when some
trace relevant event happens it just
causes the P trace call in the tracing
process to get informed
is that a question also no no no just
stretching okay alrighty thank you very
much
[Applause]